The joe rogan experience.
You know what's amazing is,
um,
how well kids can
manipulate their body to my,
my daughter can do a,
what is that called?
When you put your feet on the ground,
your back bends and you put your hand.
Yeah,
right there.
A little spines are so
incredibly flexible and you know,
and she can go up on their
tippy toes and she's only six.
She can also climb a rope.
I have a rope in my garage.
You've seen my garage is
preeclampsia the only great,
she grabs that rub and climbs
all the way to the top.
And I was watching her do that.
I was like,
how many women can do that?
Like she's a tiny little girl.
She's six.
Like how many grown women can support
their own weight like that and climb a
budge?
Grown man can't do it.
No.
Most my,
yeah,
most grown men,
they couldn't climb a rope if their
life actually dependent on it.
Yeah.
And that's sad.
It is sad.
And that's one of the best
things I ever did for my kid.
I just hung a rope in
our foyer of our house.
We had like one of those
cargo architecturally designed
houses that the kitchen
went up three fours,
you know,
with uh,
like a,
uh,
by level type thing,
split level.
And uh,
took my life in my own
hands with my drill.
Tried to hang that damn broke man.
I tied myself a with my Jujitsu about and
was leaning over the back and he tried
to find a,
a beam with a beam finder and the,
you know,
got the drill.
This is all while they actually
wife was out of the house.
She comes home,
she has this rope hanging down in the
middle of her foyer by our kitchen.
And uh,
you know,
I got both kids climbing.
That rope is at the beginning
of the divorce proceedings.
Probably my whole,
for the moment I said I do with the
beginning of the divorce proceeding.
That's how it works.
Sometimes it's just the
idea of getting married,
let's,
we're going to be normal.
We're going to be like everybody else.
We're going to get married.
Well,
it'll work out once
we're married or workout.
It never does,
man.
I preferred and marriage.
Right.
And unmarried is where I have my money.
She has hers,
I got my credit card,
she has hers,
I have my possessions,
she has hers.
I don't tell her what to do.
She doesn't tell me what to do.
You know,
it's like an agreement.
We're together because
we want to be together.
We don't need a government agency to
tell us that we can live together and we
definitely don't need a government agency
telling us that we're allowed to be a
partner.
Well,
that doesn't sound very romantic stuff.
I don't know what kind of
woman's can accept that,
but I'll tell you right now,
I am not going to,
I'll tell you right now,
Steve,
I want a traditional marriage.
I know we won't be able to tell
my friends and I'm married.
That's the other thing.
Chicks love to tell their
friends who married,
very few guys like you're excited to tell
their friends they're getting married.
Like,
see,
I got her.
She's marrying me.
I did it.
You know,
they go,
Yay,
we're good.
We're getting married.
Like,
well,
congratulations.
But it's never like this
milestone accomplishment.
Like,
wow,
you pulled it off,
but a girl will like,
look,
I'm kidding me.
Like,
oh my God,
I can't believe in girls.
They get so excited.
I'm so happy for you.
They'll hug.
It's a complete different
experience for the male.
Women have got it in their head,
which some I should say because
of movies and of the stories.
You know this romantic happily
ever after idea that they have to,
they have to get legally bound.
They don't think of it as,
you know,
it's you.
The way you look at it
as so harsh and so jaded.
It's not a legal contract.
It's,
it's a beautiful agreement and it's you
take your relationship to a next level.
Yeah.
Until you hit those divorce
proceedings and then you realize,
oh,
this is a contract.
Like this is a legal
contract with the state,
and now I've got to bring in lawyers and
we've got to figure out how to fucking
divvy up my money and the lawyers
get a giant chunk of that action.
That's the big scam.
That's what's when I'm Phil Hartman,
before his wife killed him,
when he was trying to get divorced,
shot him in his sleep.
He um,
was ranting to me,
but I go just fucking give
her half and he was like,
it's not a half.
That's the thing.
It's a third because the
lawyers get a third too.
You'll lose two thirds.
It's not half pretty much man.
It was just steam it as well.
I like done the non marriage,
you know,
that's nice than non marriage.
The line keeps their own personality and
you don't like just get all wrapped up.
See this Guy Jamie was showing me
these yesterday's Russian oligarch 4.5
billion.
I in a divorce.
Of course.
I guess when you have billions in Bellin's
is probably not that big of a deal.
Yeah,
it's a big deal.
No matter how much money you got,
the idea that some chick is going to be
going off bang another dudes with your
money and riding Ferrari's and flying
private jets everywhere and buying castles
all with your cash.
Why?
Because he had sex with her.
I guess they don't have prenups
in Russia or if they do,
he didn't get one.
I mean,
he's just maybe thought
it was going to be,
this is going to be different man.
Fuck all the other 50% of the
people that could make it.
I'm not even hedging my bets.
I'm all in.
He pushed all his chips
on the table and you know,
the thing that I think
sours a lot of marriages,
and I can speak from experience because
I've been married and divorced three
times,
three times,
three times.
You fucking crazy,
man,
man.
I keep going back from Warren.
I finally got smart.
You know,
I
pretty crazy.
Wow.
So many of us guys,
we,
we get,
we get the,
uh,
a woman who was the,
what I call it,
the girl,
you know,
really fun to be around very,
feminine,
uh,
just you relate to,
together as friends
and then what do we do?
We turn around and
change her into a mother,
you know,
and mother is a whole different animal,
a whole different being
than that girl that,
that,
that young girl that was carefree and Yup.
And Fun to be around.
And you go to the movies and you'd go
out and you'd play and you'd just have a
great time and all that just goes right
out the window once you turn her into a
mother.
And I'm not even talking about kids,
you know,
I've seen plenty of people without kids.
The woman's still becomes the mother.
Oh yeah.
You know,
like a mother substitute.
Well,
they become a dominant role.
The man's decision making
and they sort of Cook,
Cook,
control him in a very motherly way.
I think that becomes very
unattractive to women too.
Like I don't think a lot of women,
like the man that they
didn't like that role.
I mean,
they didn't want to be put into that role.
You know,
a lot of women,
you know,
they,
they had like a strong guy
that kind of take care of them.
Right.
Well,
I don't know.
I mean,
I wouldn't want to generalize,
but the,
what I've seen from the
women that dominate the men,
the,
like the guys that I know with
a woman tells him what to do.
And those guys also have
a hard time getting sex.
Like almost universally,
it's almost,
it's almost like a rule.
Like if the woman dominates and the
woman tells you what to do and the woman
does control your spending and controls,
you know what your hobbies are and tells
you what's going to happen and where
are you going to go.
Those guys don't get much sex.
And I don't know if that's related to
like a woman being attracted to a man that
she can't control or not attracted
to a man she can control rather well.
The mother doesn't like sex.
The mother is against sex.
And that's what happens so
often in these marriages.
And you know,
I've had a lot of women that
are misuses and you know,
they uh,
body workers and man,
when,
you know,
they tell me it's uncanny how many other
male clients will always proposition
and tried to rankle sex out of them,
raising legitimate.
It was like,
I'm not talking about prostitutes.
Right,
right,
right.
And I mean it's pretty common.
Yeah.
Guys are just sex starved.
Did their relationships,
their marriages.
But the thing that really used to rankle
me most more than anything was the way
women would not want to be.
They would want to separate
their guys from their,
their,
their friends.
And they really resented the fact that
God has come to two Shitzu trading as it
got the owned it you,
she's at school,
man,
the,
the wives and girlfriends would give
the guys such a hard time about gone and
train it.
If anything,
they should be encouraged and they
got to go as much as possible.
And you know,
they pulled these guys out of there and
that's a damn shame to do that to a guy.
It's also damn shame for a guy to pull
his woman out of something that she loves
to do.
Oh well yeah,
of course.
I mean,
to be fair,
of course,
yeah.
It's,
it's a terrible thing when people
try to change the person who they're,
they love and control them.
I mean,
could you imagine your
friend doing that to you?
Like a friend going,
come on man,
you're not going to work out.
What are you working out for?
I don't want you working out.
Hey,
You're my friend.
You're coming with me.
And like what?
Like I don't like you camping,
camping,
you know I don't like
you going to ball games.
He'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking crazy?
But when that friend happens to be
someone that you have sex with or you're
romantically connected to girlfriend,
fiance,
wife,
whatever you want to call it,
that person all of a sudden has a some
sort of a role they can dictate like your
actual day,
like dictate what you do,
whether it's a guy doing it to a wife or
a girlfriend or a woman doing it to her
husband or her boyfriend.
It's a weird thing that people just sort
of accept ed the Ed and it happens so
often and it's always gross.
No wonder that divorces
at its all time highs,
right?
Fucking idiots.
All of us to three jobs.
Did you think about on number three
when that one failed and you like,
motherfucker,
what's wrong with me?
Why don't I do this three times?
Pretty much.
It was like,
damn you,
man.
I had a lot of shame actually,
and a lot of feelings of
unworthiness or whatever,
you know?
I like the feeling of being
a failure and all that,
and then I just realized,
well,
you know,
some people just aren't cut out.
I should have never been in
that situation the first.
Okay,
okay.